hey guys now most of us want to improve
our lives
but many of us think that we can't do it
because we don't have enough
money well there are some things cheap
items
that you can get that will help you to
improve your life
what is it well that's what we're going
to talk about in this video
let's get right into it
i have a dream that's all i need
but mistakes make you strong all right
now for you who are here for the first
time
welcome to my channel my name is daniel
meretz now let's start with the first
item
a french press coffee plunger now to
have great coffee
you don't need to buy an expensive
coffee machine
all you need to do is just buy a cheap
coffee plunger
you and your guests will definitely
appreciate it
it's simple add coffee add warm water
wait two to five minutes
press it down and there you go great
tasting
coffee and just remember i'll add all
the links for you in the video
description
down below just to make it a bit easier
for you if you want to go and check it
out
roll on antiperspirant you just can't
leave your home
without it if you forgot go back and put
it on
i just can't believe how many guys don't
do it and you smell them
in a gym in the subway in the school or
the office
and even if you use that body spray is
not as effective
because those bad odors they creep
through after a few hours of work
a pocket knife nothing is as manly as a
pocket knife
and yes there are expensive ones but you
can get cheap ones
in the old days no man and i mean no man
walked without his pocket knife i
remember my granddad
he was a farmer and he never left the
house without
his pocket knife so get one and i assure
you
it's always going to come in handy and
remember the knife
does not make the man so don't feel
arrogant if you've got a nice looking
knife
no a knife is only as good as the one
who wields it a quote by patrick ness
[Music]
a personalized coffee mug this is a
personal thing
i love good coffee and i also love
my personalized coffee mug i actually
love it so much that i
actually have a few of them and if
you've got a business
it's a great way and cheap to promote
your brand
and get your customers excited about it
a basic toolbox if you're low on money
don't get a
big toolbox or power tools just get a
basic one
all you need is a basic cheap toolbox
that will equip you
to fix those basic problems in your
house or
in your car a daily planner
if your time is limited you need a daily
planner
i use it every single day why because
it's always better to get all these
plans and ideas in my head
done on paper and to prioritize it and
then
if you like writing then get a journal
to explore those ideas of yours even
more
air freshener you know every single
person has a unique
smell to them and the problem is you get
used
to your own smell and that smell hangs
around in your house in your car
and then when you get visitors that
smell smacks him right in the face
so just get a cheap air freshener in
your car in your home
and that'll sort out all the other
strange odors as well
a basic grooming kit look you don't need
to go expensive here
but you do need the basics and you can
get it for cheap
in a basic kit you need a trimmer a
razor a tweezer
body lotion toothbrush toothpaste
shampoo and conditioner nail clipper
earwax
or pomade then of course if you've got a
beard you also need hair shampoo
oil and wax
a small flashlight it's always going to
help you to see better under
your bed under a car under a sofa even
and it will definitely help you when the
power goes out
and here in south africa it happens a
lot
load shedding earplugs they're not
expensive and they help a lot now you
guys know that i travel a lot and
there's always
noise around you big cities of airports
a subway
it's always people talking children cars
oh man sometimes i just want to go and
live on an island
somewhere where it's quiet where i'm
alone but yeah
earplugs do help as well
[Music]
a unique pen again you don't need to go
and buy a very expensive pen
just one that is unique for some reason
it just feels great to write your daily
schedule
your goals basically your life with a
unique
pen libon
the weather is always changing and you
need to take care of your lips
so it's simple just get lip balm
shoe polish you know instead of buying
new shoes every now and then
just learn how to take care of the ones
you already got
you know so many guys throw away their
money because they never learn to be
responsible
to take care of the things that they
already have
and then when it breaks or they lose it
they need to buy new ones all the time
and then they complain they never have
money now guys
responsibility be responsible and have
some pride in your own things
[Music]
wear gloves now whether you work on your
bike or your car
or on your home wear gloves respect
yourself enough to take care of your
body and that includes your hands
you don't want your girlfriend or wife
to look at your hands and cringe with
disgust
because over all the years those marks
they add up
and while you get a cut or something you
lose time because you got to wait until
that cut heals before you can go at it
again
with your 100 a good umbrella
you know they so those people who say no
just be positive you know the glass half
full and
other people that last half empty well
the truth is it's none of those
the truth is it's just half and so a
rainy day
is gonna come whether you like it or not
and when it happens you want to prepare
it
i actually just gone a little bit deeper
here than just talking about normal rain
you guys know what i'm talking about but
yeah when it happens you want to be
prepared
not just for yourself but for those
around you you can be a gentleman for
the woman that's close to you
and a man with a nice umbrella it just
looks
stylish a real gentleman
a car charger i always keep it in my car
i can't
even count the number of times it saved
my life or actually my
phone's life because my phone would have
died anyway
a car charger your own
water bottle now not only is it going to
remind you
to drink enough water but it's also
going to help you to stay away from
those other bottles
that contains bpa bisphenol a you don't
want that
now i've already talked about this in
another video so i'm not going to talk
about it here again
but when you do get a bottle get one
that's bpa
free a pet
now every guy needs a pet in his life to
teach him responsibility
caring and love and if you hate animals
you don't deserve them in the first
place it does tell people a lot
about you the way you treat animals now
i recommend
a dog because men they always have
unconditional love for people
and you don't need to buy one there's
many at the spca
looking for a loving home
tissues and wet wipes why because you're
gonna need it
and if you don't have it it's gross you
know those times when you
want to sneeze a monster sneeze and it
always comes out or
those times when you have a runny nose
or when your hands are dirty
you're in the car and you just wish you
had some wet wipes
i know some guys use a handkerchief but
i just i could never understand it
because how is it possible that you can
oh take all that gunk you put it in that
handkerchief and then you put it back in
your pocket
it stays there while you walk the whole
day
no thank you
[Music]
a copy of your favorite book what's your
favorite book
if you don't have one it's time to get
one i've got a few
actually but my most favorite the bible
and if you didn't know i was a christian
don't judge me
i wasn't always a christian i used to be
an arrogant
selfish guy i just cared about himself
and then i lost my two brothers and it
changed my life
if you want to hear my whole story then
you can watch it in this video here
that's on my other channel
and i'll see you there that's it from me
guys see you next video
cheers